the toronto police
puts out this tweet
and it's a news release it says
news release
missing woman
okay missing woman that's the picture
missing woman ryerson avenue and
bathurst street area isabella degrassi
27.
so i look at this looks like what to me
looks like a man right i'm not i'm not
losing my mind
okay
so i'm thinking oh here we go here we go
down this road let's start right you're
like jed you had to start with the crazy
i did there's a very important reason
because i have to remind you all that we
need a good laugh in life so i scroll
down and i see
i don't know who this person is but it's
af632 god bless you whoever you are
puts this tweet up in response tyler can
we pull that tweet
got it you have it yeah
there we go okay
missing dog
please help do you guys see what's going
on here the crazy obviously that's a cat
obviously that's a cat but do you see
how much people have lost their minds
that guy or girl i don't know who af 632
is decided i am going to make a mockery
of this moment now we can all laugh we
can also i've told you that you know my
kid sometimes identifies as a monkey you
know curious george
i've told you that my dog identifies as
more of a gerbil than a dog because
she's very small and she's you know
doesn't have quite the bark that a
german shepherd or rottweiler would have
she's feeling a little insufficient in
that department
and we can laugh about this and believe
me i did i laughed heartily when i saw
that because i was like thank god
somebody picked up this moment and just
made us all laugh but do you also
realize the crazy of
this is a missing person alert
i have to pray somewhere tear to the god
god the universe please was this a joke
were you playing some type of trick on
me
because i also then in that moment think
oh my gosh what if there was a
uh somebody who escaped a prisoner or
a criminal out there and you know how
cops get those alerts what's it gonna
say
missing woman and it's a guy and you're
out there looking for some woman and
it's think about how the crazy can go
from funny
to actually dangerous and scary i had to
lead with that
we're going to do a new segment on the
show too related to tweets so i'm just
going to be encouraging you to be
funnier and crazier on twitter so we can
pull it and add it to the show but that
really like is a great opener for some
of the things we're going to discuss
today
when i saw that i started to think about
like who looks at that and thinks okay
that's crazy versus who looks at it and
thinks oh well that's how that person
identifies and that's how we should talk
about them
so i checked out a poll
interesting poll
from the new york post
60 of americans say that people can't
switch genders this is a new poll from
years past it says a new survey released
by the pew research center states that
60 of adults say a person's gender is
determined by their sex assigned at
birth
wow those 60 must be nuts
what do they think in those neanderthals
antiquated talking about how you're born
with a certain anatomy and that defines
your gender
crazy people right no not so much
what's interesting about this poll
though this is a four point increase
from the previous year so it was 56 in
2021
so the more that the woke community is
shoving this in everybody's face and
saying no we have to normalize this we
have to normalize that this is a man who
became a woman and now you need to call
the more they force it
the more people are saying
no i don't no i don't want that that
seems off to me like do whatever you
want with your life but that's not an
accurate
depiction of what's going on biology is
biology people are resisting it
more
because it's being shoved down their
throats which was very interesting to me
also interesting the survey found that
86 of republicans and those leading
republican believe gender is determined
by sex assigned at birth
but only 38 of democrats believe that
okay so we see where the problem lies do
we not
we see where the problem lies
this is going to be
a really big problem for democrats
really big problem not the hey live the
life you want we don't want you to be
discriminated we want you to be able not
that
not that what's going to be a really big
problem is ignoring biology
what's going to be a really big problem
is saying menstruating people a lot aoc
or birthing people what's going to be a
really big problem is you know pushing
puberty blockers for kids and gender
reassignment surgeries as if it's not
problematic
for young people
if they want to toe these lines
if they want to make this their priority
if they want to make this their platform
so be it go do what you got to do it's
going to be a loss for you people are
are
now paying attention
and we always talk about how like the
fringe in the left runs the party
and then some and then some
so i thought this was really interesting
also in that poll which is interesting
is the study's findings
on transgender athletes
are consistent with another poll from
the university of maryland which found
that 58 of americans believe transgender
women should be barred from competing in
college or professional sports that's
more than half of people are saying no
what's going on here no good
doesn't work for me not gonna work so
that's just an important i don't believe
all polls
but i do i do believe this one because
you talking into
you go into communities and you talk to
people and they're like okay
what's going on
all right we have another tweet this was
all connected it was like i i opened the
floodgates of the gender conversation
and it all came to me what do you know
disclose tv which on twitter is really
interesting they have some great content
they put this tweet up
new from mid-2023
according to planned legislation in
germany everyone over the age of 14 will
be able to change their gender and first
name once a year well look at that
the governing party's announced today
granted this is in germany not in the
u.s but
what happens over there is this is where
we're headed right so you wake up
this year you're a girl
and you change your name and next year
you're a boy
and maybe the third year you're a cat or
dog who knows maybe you can even be an
iguana we're in florida who knows
this is a clown show guys
this there's no other way to say it this
is a clown show and i talk a lot about
the danger of this because if words
don't have meaning nothing you're not
grounded in anything remember that
if a boy's not a boy and a girl's not a
girl and i know it's like well people
say well who cares it doesn't affect you
no it does affect me actually
it does affect me because i'm grounded
in something called reality
reality is quickly vanishing and
everything is in the abstract and i
don't want to live in the wizard of oz
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]